WE WERE ONCE YOUNG,
AND THEN HUDSON'S BAY COMPANY
CAME AND TOOK ALL THE FURS.
AND SO IT'S THE PAIN
OF THE CANADIAN PEOPLE.
ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR.
[generic electronic beat
with simple effects]
YEAH, TURN THAT BAD BOY UP
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
LOUDER, FASTER, YEAH.
OOH, THAT'S BETTER.
[beat stops]
UH--
[triangle dings]
- PARDON, SORRY,
BUT WAS THAT THE SONG?
- ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR.
[beat resumes]
LITTLE FAST.
THIS IS MURRAY, MY SOBER COACH.
- PARDON, BUT IS THE SONG
OF CANADA
JUST A DRUM BEAT
ON A CASIO KEYBOARD?
- OKAY, WELL, YOU'RE A BITCH,
JUST LIKE MY EX-WIFE,
SO LET'S
[bleep] DO IT THEN.
I HATE TO [bleep] SWEAR.
I'M NOT GOING TO SWEAR,
BUT THIS CRAP--IS THAT BETTER?
IS NO [bleep] GOOD.
[beat resumes]
IS THAT--
IS THAT [bleep]
TASTIER FOR YOU?
- THANKS SO MUCH.
YOU MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ROUND.
- MY SONGS ARE GOING TO BE
MAGIC.
- I'VE LOVED MAGIC
SINCE I WAS A BOY.
- AND I WILL NEED A VOLUNTEER
TO PICK A CARD.
- UH-OH, LOOKS LIKE
WE GOT ONE HERE.
- YEAH.
SO PLEASE--
THIS IS A DECK OF CARDS,
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT
ALL THE CARDS ARE DIFFERENT.
TAKE ANY CARD OUT OF THE DECK.
- ANY ONE?
- ANY ONE YOU'D LIKE.
- MAYBE DO A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTORTION.
- WELL, I JUST NEED YOU
TO PICK A CARD.
[applause]
OKAY...
IT'S KIND OF MESH ON YOUR--
- IT'S DIFFICULT BECAUSE--
- YEAH, IT MIGHT BE EASIER
TO JUST TAKE WITH YOUR HANDS.
OKAY, DON'T SHOW ME.
- OKAY, I DIDN'T SHOW
YOU WHAT I HAVE.
- OH.
- CAN YOU SHOW US?
- OKAY, YOU SEE WHAT
THE CARD IS?
- YOU GOT THAT CARD, TORONTO?
- OKAY, HERE WE GO.
TELL ME WHEN TO STOP SHUFFLING.
- STOP.
- RIGHT HERE?
WHAT WAS YOUR CARD?
- IT WAS THE KING OF DIAMONDS.
- THAT'S IT.
CRACKERS!
OH, GOOD GOD.
- NO WAY!
- OH, GOD.
- HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
YOU'RE AMAZING.
- THANK YOU.
- ALL RIGHT.
- NEXT TIME,
IF I USE YOU AGAIN,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT,
'CAUSE THAT KIND OF UPSTAGES ME.
YOU CAN TAKE A CARD
WITH YOUR HANDS NEXT TIME.
- OKAY.
- THANK YOU.
- OKAY, TORONTO, WE'VE COME
TO THE END OF THE SHOW.
IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO VOTE, EH?
FOR JON LAJOIE, TEXT ONE-ONE.
FOR THE UNFINISHED CANADIAN SONG
OF DOUG GARY, TEXT ONE-ONE.
FOR THE HILARIOUS COMEDY OF
GRAHAM THE COMEDIAN,
YOU'RE GONNA TEXT ONE-ONE.
FOR THE CRAZY THINGS
OF AMY AMNESIA,
YOU TEXT ONE-ONE,.
AND THEN FOR THE MAGIC
OF "MAGIC" NATHAN,
YOU GOTTA TEXT ONE-ONE.
- EVERYBODY ON SHOW US YOUR
SONGS, TORONTO, IS A WINNER.
AND THE VOTES WILL PROVE THAT
SHORTLY.
- OOPS, HERE WE GO.
HERE WE GO.
OKAY, ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
WE GOT A WINNER HERE.
AND...EVERYONE'S A WINNER.